buenas tardes
así es como decía andrés estamos aquí en
la sede de este domingo para gustavo
petro y francia market es el mismo
movistar arena uno de los principales
centros de eventos que hay en bogotá por
el momento se espera también que vengan
militantes congresistas a recibir los
resultados junto a gustavo petro y
francia- market pero de momento la
llegada está siendo escasa
recordemos que en este centro de bota en
este centro de esta campaña después hay
de ir de campaña de gustavo petro perdón
hay capacidad para más de 15.000
personas y ellos esperan llenar lo hemos
hablado también con gente del equipo de
gustavo petro nos han dicho que están
tranquilos que los tracking se tienen
internos les son favorables algo
habitual que se dice en estos casos pero
que habrá que esperar a ver porque saben
que va a ser una votación muy reñida y
que también creen participación a su
vida y si alcanza a ver un poco detrás
de usted un sinnúmero de cámaras que nos
puede decir sobre la presencia de la
prensa allí
[Música]
sí sí sí se ven detrás muchas cámaras
delante de mí se ven aún incluso más
este movistar arena la ciudad solución
que ha tenido el equipo de petro después
de que en la primera vuelta presidencial
les fuimos en el hotel tequendama unos
principales hoteles de bogotá y se quedó
pequeño en esta ocasión había entre 250
y 400 medios acreditados y hoy nos han
dicho que hay 600 medios acreditados
tanto nacionales e internacionales las
principales cadenas del mundo también
están por aquí cerca a nuestros
compañeros de las cadenas hermanas en
inglés y en francés y toda esta
aglomeración de periodistas ha
dificultado un poco el acceso en la
logística y además ha coincidido con la
lluvia de bogotá un día sido lluvioso en
colombia en el caribe en el pacífico
también aquí en la capital y nos ha
caído tanto a mi compañero camarógrafo a
lionel fischer y ya me un poco de agua